[Music]
sabine hostenfelder welcome to how the
light gets in
nice to meet you
um so can said this famous quote the two
things filled his mind with all in
admiration the story happens above him
and the moral law within him
do you have a feeling of or an
admiration towards the universe
sometimes sometimes more so sometimes
less so depending on what news page i
look at uh
i mean there's certainly a reason i went
into science because
that's what inspires me um
so
certainly that plays into my motivation
to go on with my research
and is it is it hard to revisit that
sort of feeling of
oh and kind of mystery
many years down the road when you're
when you're a researcher and you're
caught in the thick of it
it's kind of interesting how much my
interests have changed over the time
like when i started out doing physics
like 20 years ago i was very much into
particle physics you know i thought
that's the most interesting thing ever
like what's metamate of what are the
smallest things and how does everything
hold together you know how does the
whole universe
get built up of these tiny things
and i i've drifted away from this
towards more
you could say philosophical questions
about how much can we actually really
understand using mathematics about the
origin of the universe about also the
structure of matter but also
what we mean by a measurement you know
can we take the human out of the
equation uh that kind of thing yeah
absolutely and in relation to that i
mean you've
long argued against sort of looking for
beauty in physics and how mathematics
can somehow lead physics astray down
sort of rabbit holes
um
even if there isn't a place for beauty
and physics is there still a place for
creativity you think
is physics a creative endeavor
yeah you're phrasing this a little bit
more strongly than i intended it to be
it's not that i say there's no place for
beauty and physics what i object to is
that a lot of physicists in particular
theory development
use very constraining
notions of beauty and they just assume
that nature has to fulfill them
and
what the argument that i make in my book
lost in math how beauty leads physics
astray is that if you start with the
assumption that nature has to be
beautiful in a particular way for which
you have a mathematical expression and
you use this as an assumption for your
theory development
that's the wrong way to go about it
instead we should be looking at nature
with an open mind and i think that's how
we will find new beauty so it's not like
there's no beauty
but i i don't like it that physicists
use beauty in this very narrow
sense
so you're asking is there a place for
creativity and science well it's pretty
much impossible to do science without
creativity um but it's it's kind of a
very constrained type of creativity uh
compared to the arts where you have a
lot of freedom
whereas in science it's very technical
to some extent you know there are lots
of rules you have to obey and you can't
just say well i'll break them a little
bit right you're not allowed to do this
and then theoretical physics in
particular a lot of those rules are just
mathematics um you you you just you
can't just say well i'll forget about
the mathematics and um stop believing in
it
so apart from sort of this this notion
of beauty physics is also driven by
other values and a kind of key one is
simplicity right theoretical physics for
a very long time has been trying to get
a unified theory of everything having
one simple sort of
model that explains everything do you
think that's also a sort of wrong
motivation to be looking for simplicity
and singularity in physics or is it
actually helping drive physics
innovation
so there are actually two different
notions of simplicity one of which is
just i would say a natural ingredient of
science which is that you should make a
theory more complicated than it has to
be and so if you have some kind of
theory doesn't really matter what it is
you shouldn't add unnecessary
assumptions
um and that's really really important i
think to some extent physicists
themselves don't really understand how
important this is because if you don't
have this assumption
you cannot you can always do something
like saying and god made it right and
that would be a justified assumption
but the reason we throw it out is that
you don't need it um to actually make a
prediction with the theory
and so this is what you could call
occam's razor
don't make any unnecessary assumptions
but there's a different kind of
simplicity that
especially in the foundations of physics
scientists often refer to which is what
you just said we're looking for a theory
that's just
simple period
and
that's certainly driven to some extent
by looking at the history of physics
where we have seen a turn towards
simplification
you know we had this
uh periodic table you know with all
these different elements and then we
explained them by way of quantum
mechanics that explains all these energy
levels in the properties of the elements
and then we discovered the atomic
nucleus and
the
constituents of the nucleus and those
constituents were themselves made of
other things and we ended up with this
fairly simple
theory which is called the standard
model of particle physics where we have
like 25 particles that makes up the
entire universe i still find this
stunning
so that's certainly simple but it could
be simpler
and
that's certainly driven a lot of
research in physics
and
at this point you have to ask like does
it really have to be simpler like does
there have to be something simpler than
this
and i think we just don't know so i
don't think it's a good assumption to
start from that the next better theory
that we find necessarily has to be
simpler
so going back to philosophy that you
mentioned earlier your your interest
drifting in that direction and
thinking about where the human is
place in all this concepts like
measurement and the subjectivity that we
bring with it do you think science will
be able to accommodate those
eventually accommodate human
subjectivity and the human kind of
perspective of the world or is that
always going to be something that's left
for philosophers to discuss
well
i would say it's more something for
sociologists to discuss
but
it's kind of it's quite funny actually i
think that a lot of what counts as
philosophy is actually more sociology of
science so those two are closer related
than i think philosophers would like
them to be
so
i've been very interested in
figuring out how much we can possibly
learn about the origin of the universe
and it's
when you speak to people who work on
this they seem to vastly overestimate
how far we can go with the scientific
method
and then we have in the in the
foundations of physics and quantum
mechanics we have this issue with the
measurement problem and there's been
like a hundred years debate over whether
or not we need to understand the role of
the observer in it
and also it may it leads to the question
like what do we mean by an observer to
begin with
and i think these are super important
questions that physicists kind of prefer
to not acknowledge which makes things
easier but it also means
that you may be making a big mistake
without even noticing
so do you think that philosophy can
philosophy of science and philosophers
that think about these kind of the
questions left
untackled by by science can that
discussion influence how science
develops or is philosophy always just
sort of describing and kind of
theorizing about what science already is
doing
do you think do you think philosophy of
science can have an impact on on physics
and how it develops
it can
whether it will
i don't know it's certainly the case
that a lot of physicists are kind of not
very friendly with philosophers they
tend to find pretty much everything that
comes out of philosophy useless
i don't share this opinion but it's
certainly something that i observe among
my colleagues and i have to say
to some extent it's justified because a
lot of what comes out of philosophy
actually isn't particularly useful
and
a lot of it is just looking at what
scientists do and then trying to make
sense of it
and i think they that philosophers
should be a little bit more proactive
you know they should actually go and say
this isn't okay and this won't lead
anywhere and we've made this mistake
before and you should have learned from
it but you shouldn't but you didn't um
so i think there's a bigger role for
philosophers to be played in the
foundations of physics yeah i think what
you're saying is particularly true when
it comes to something like the
philosophy of time like i
can see many philosophers who just sort
of take the findings of theoretical
physics about time and then try and
figure out what they mean rather than
kind of challenge them and very much
very quickly are happy to concede that
time is an illusion where it doesn't
really exist or things like that is that
the sort of thing that you have in mind
for philosophers to kind of challenge
some of the results that are coming out
of physics so
that happened to be a topic that i'm not
personally very familiar with um
but yeah i guess it's part of the reason
is of course that a lot of the
philosophers don't really have the
necessary background to actually
question what comes out of physics so
they kind of take what comes out of
physics and then they're trying to make
sense of it
uh and
it's it's it's a similar thing when you
look at particle physics like what i
wrote about in my book like this this
notion of naturalness um it's not that
they're so much critically examining it
uh so they're more taking what comes out
of physics and then that they're trying
uh to make sense of it
um but i also know a lot of physicists
who went into philosophy or a lot of
philosophers who have some kind of
degree in physics and they do really
great work
like
for example i think in cosmology this is
becoming really really important where
we have
david merritt he recently so he's a an
astrophysicist turned philosopher and
he's re recently written a book with the
somewhat off-putting title a
philosophical approach to bond
but it's a really thorough analysis of
dark the dark matter hypothesis versus
modified uh newtonian dynamics and he's
asking like which of those two theories
actually does better explaining
evidence and he rates
these theories on the scale um
on criteria that have been provided by
uh philosophers and and i think that's
super useful now we only have to get the
astrophysicist to actually read it
and how has philosophy influenced your
work as a physicist has it made you ask
different kinds of questions than you
would have had otherwise does it impact
the kind of research that you think
you're interested in doing
how does it what's the impact of having
studied and read and thought about
philosophy in your work as a physicist
yeah it certainly influenced me i think
most prominently
with the realization that you have to be
very very careful about how you define
your terms
and you have to be very careful about
stating which assumptions you make
but also
so as i already said i've been drifting
more towards philosophy because
that's kind of where all the questions
end
in the end
and so it's naturally gotten me
interested in how much can we possibly
know
um where does our knowledge end which is
something that philosophers have written
about uh for a long time
and uh
are there some recent
big shifts in cosmology that you're
excited about is science
uh the science of physics kind of moving
forward or has it is are we going
through a kind of more stagnant period
how do you see the moment that we're in
well cosmology is an interesting topic
to mention because i actually do see
that there's some things being shaken up
you know where people were once very
very sure they have it all figured out
and now they have a lot of new data
whether like you know it doesn't really
fit in you know maybe we'll have to
think about this again
and one of those cases is for example
the cosmological principle which roughly
speaking says that the universe should
be
on on the average the same everywhere
like if you average over very large
distance scale the distribution of
matter should roughly be the same and it
it just turns out from observations it's
not the case
and that's a problem because that's one
of the assumptions that underlies the
current standard model of cosmology
which is also called the concordance
model or lambda cdm so it's all the same
thing
and
that's very interesting because if you
don't have the cosmological principle
you basically have to redo
all these data fits and that can shake
up a lot of things and it could resolve
some tensions and maybe lead to some new
discoveries
you're a big science communicator you
have your own very successful youtube
channel um you didn't start that way you
started as a blogger a science blogger
what's the difference
between the written word and the visual
kind of representation that you've found
and and you know
which of the two do you think is a
better medium for communicating science
ideas to the public
oh well i i think they're they're both
good but some work better for some
people uh somewhat better for other
people it just seems to be the case
naturally i would say that a lot of
people find it easier to follow
explanations if there's actually a
person speaking like a real human being
and they have some
audio signal
basically
also i mean a nice thing about doing
videos is that you can add animations
and graphics that's just much much
easier than if you only have the written
word and you have to find these clumsy
explanations for things with
metaphors that never quite work um so
there's definitely a benefit to
switching over to
something visual it also has a
disadvantage because there are many more
things that you have to pay attention to
basically you know if you just write you
write and then you're done with it
whereas if you make a video
not only do you have to think about the
the scientific content you also have to
think about how do i get it get it
across
um how do i speak clearly
how are these english words pronounced
so it just brings up a whole bunch of
new problems
and what are you currently working on
what's a project that you're currently
passionate about
research-wise i'm working on modified
gravity dark matter which i've been
working on for some while so we have
some papers in the pipe that will
hopefully come out by the end of the
year i'm also working on the measurement
problem in quantum mechanics
so this is where my philosophical
interests have taken me it's something i
kind of do on the side
and i just finished writing a book so
i'll have a new book coming out next
year in the summer
which is basically it's about the
intersection between philosophy and the
foundations of physics so all the big
questions also about the nature of time
is time and illusion
does the past still exist does the
universe think
all these kind of things are in my new
book
what is what do you think is the biggest
kind of question that arises from
physics that has a kind of big
philosophical question behind it
well it depends on you know do you mean
the question the biggest question for me
or the biggest question for the average
person you would meet on this
street i think what most people
care about very very deeply is free will
has physics ruled out free will and my
book has a chapter on that
so personally i'm much more fascinated
by this question like does the future
already exist which seems to be strongly
suggested at least by einstein's
theories of space and time belonging
together
and what do you think that means do you
think we can actually
change the way we sort of live our
day-to-day lives if we come to that
realization that time is an illusion
time is the future is fixed it's all
laid out like a map and we're just
navigating it in some ways or is this
always going to be
just an intellectual exercise for us
it depends very strongly on what you
mean by change
so
arguably
as we live our life we have to make
decisions and you could say those
decisions
make a change
in your life for example so that's one
notion of change you can talk about and
that's perfectly compatible with the
deterministic time evolution
now if you're asking
had there actually been different
possible futures and did i get to choose
one of them
that just isn't compatible with the laws
of nature that we uh currently have
okay so i've been hustling filter thank
you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv